[音楽]
なぜ生が初だと思います今からすることを頑張ります
ani
さあならまだ音です
では
[音楽]
行ってきます
ああああああ
8 c
見てきます
バレないバレないよございま pou dou dou
[音楽]
わたわたああ
ございません
これ
どこに向かっているとかな通販もう富士急でしょ
goo
[音楽]
やっぱりえもん
最強のジェットコースター内山のコースの上を歩いてるドッキリ
仕掛けていきたいとおもいますいうわけで今回のターゲット層はさんと富士急に車で来
たんですけども
相馬さんに企画アバと聞かせてないんですけども内山が前で待ち合わせしましょうと
いうことに今待たせております
はじめしゃちょーさせておくんですけど
フュージョンありがとう遊んでますよ走った
ちょっとどこですかもう早い新聞でだめじゃん
相馬さんが待っているフジヤマの頭上79m 上笹がに藤山だコースの上で待ってると
思わないで
アースの上で俺が待ってたらどういうリアクションをするのかというドッキリ仕掛けて
いきたいとおもい
もうこんな機会ないと思うんでてかもあの危険なので真似しないで下さいっていうかも
真似できないと思うんですけどもしっかり許可をとって実施しております安全も確保し
ておりますではご覧ください
どうぞまず登らなきゃださあそこからが
[音楽]
これ何メートルでしたっけ
魔獣龍79
いつも乗ってるコースを歩いてる
[音楽]
付きましたねーおおぉ
すごいすごいすごい
[音楽]
ちょっと休憩してるよそれではどれくらいですかねぇ
書いてある分かりやす日本20m 2
いつでも相当よくれ ok いきます
二冊目たです
[音楽]
高いなぁ
名前やはちょっとまず交換できた作業車
40m ですもう高い
大高いぞ
[拍手]
めっちゃ綺麗でも今半分ですか
まずはこれぐらいファーん
後ろが高い長芋救っ
ちょっと消しています足がすくみますねー
てよねー
リザーからかタコとかな方だぞってすごい
言ってない
ぬ困難の時間分
こんなことあるん
wh
[音楽]
ていました60m やっぱり使えますか
だったドジしきーなー
すごいよもうだいぶ登ってを盗んの必要消化
[音楽]
プラずメロというします
断崖絶壁がこんな貴重な経験ないよあと9メートルですねー
乗っちゃいますいやっほおおおおお
どういう状況だろマジで
女 youtube つっててこんなタイトルが見えないと始めるっ
でも遊んで打ったリック初めてとかぜひ取り入れねー
よし大台町はぁ
ホライズンじゃねぇ
てこの
java いいよ59[ __ ]高いところできました
ん
[音楽]
ame
[拍手]
ますみなさんここが藤山の鉄製79m ですありがとうございます
いやまず普通の人間はここ歩いてると思わないねぇ
どういう顔するのかな
あとはターゲットは必須かどうかですある中急に薄くなりましたけど
ああ
うわぁでちょっと待ってまた急による2級でないからいいんだって国家が見たらこれを
使用感の良さ魅力しちゃな何があるんだぞ
[音楽]
amaran
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおお
ドランディースター
me
第2子ねぇ
[音楽]
いうところしていません
そのしっかり見てください moon
n ame
ana
うぇい
うぇい気づいたかさあな山
ぶれさでしょ
[音楽]
me
ええええっ
さっき吐いあれ
はバー工場へ
いいいいいい
ああああああ
me
[音楽]
一番近いを下げるこっち来いってダウうりうレベルファイブとらんですかぁー
を4回8 f flf
paipan
ha
ビビンバ6でダイスここは a
[拍手]
バッハ
教師つきました頂上で stage
ねえ大少し
そしてっ頬大事だぞ
知事
2 r
ana
can you do
[拍手]
[音楽]
ブービー to do
俺様だこんなところであれなんですけどなんねーの数字やまとまってるかって言うと
ですねじゃあまたってや展望台です
ですよでも作ってるじゃないまあ休止してるって感じで
こういう機会をいただけているですソーダず山田ができたらぜひ来てくださいね
急すぎませんこっからねってやばいでしょ怖い
そうだぞ
そんなきましょうか
2つこの先ヤバくないすか見ていいですねー俺女でしたねこれまたおりますよ
脚気どっ
よかっても通っているやはりしゃべるようですよね
街道のファイルっ
やばいこれすげー
急ですねんっ
そうじゃないですかオリマー前にはそもそもさん
ずっと母本当にやあ高は伊那これでも
用例
やっぱりいっ
ええええええ
ん
そうだノーチャイム者
[音楽]
もうちょいよ
はんこうやってるとめちゃくちゃおもろいかなぁ
その次さんへい
me
ハープーン穴水ブーブレない頑張ります
こんなに強いと思わなかったんですよヤバイよヤバイ質疑 by スプーンに楽しかっ
たと言えないですけどいい経験になりましたよなんか強く市でそうですねあと実は次は
高飛車ので歩いてみましょう